j'aimerais que vous nous donnez votre
avis sur quelques émissions de télé
voilà les conduire alors c'est parti
regardez on a l'amour est dans le pré
l'amour est dans le pré
à rennes on ouvre donc très c'est la
présentatrice qui va manger du
calendaire à la télé en direct soit par
aref écoulés depuis par athènes de
donner un défi aux agriculteurs qui fait
un trou dans une tasse thé faire ça jeff
dans la défense des pastèques non c'est
pas ma baignoire on ne pouvait pas dire
ça jeff et jean-marc alors capitte
capitaine marc loos le nouveau nom ni
trop quoi vous dire merci sur capitaine
marleau capitaine marc je comprends rien
quand on est à une personne contre rien
je pense que c'est pour ça que ça marche
the voice the voice moi j'aime bien moi
aussi je regarde moi je comprend rien et
à mon avis il ya toute la france qui a
chanté dans the voice sinon ça dure
longtemps c'est vrai que le monde est à
fond mais nikos et croient qu'ils aient
encore dirty n'ya dans le fauteuil
la france a un incroyable talent à gaza
a ressuscité hélène ségara s'écoule un
type dont il adore il a elle aussi
rennes tous une année le pépin jeune
contorsionniste non sire maison tu les
aimes bien ouais je les aime bien celle
à qui et quoi toi dont la dore eric
antoine j'adore ça un magicien qui
disparaît foot la sugar sammy est là et
là le jour de fouilles à david ginola et
marianne james et âmes d'un et ophélie
winter au mieux rêve
[Applaudissements]
et tpm ptpm témoin jeu merci grand chose
checchia une émission qui est bien aussi
c'est ballon ce ton post regarda tard
semaine tu m'envoies des petits messages
et oui j'adore des fois je hurle devant
ma télé vous avez envie d'intervenir
bon c'est pas c'est passionnant merci
vous allez voir beaucoup de couilles de
savoir quand et des pmp wallon ce temps
passait plus rien à dire à quoi le singe
mais il est fan pour de vrai sur moi
jean marc antoine émission pour incarner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]